The Joe Rogan experience.
What if any research have you done on artificial intelligence and robotics and
autonomous weapons and the future of warfare,
which a lot of people think it's going to be like what we're seeing now in Yemen
with drones that we're going to be seeing that with robots on the ground and
that this will be the future.
Huge amount for the book that I wrote called the Pentagon's brain.
Really impactful moment was going to Los Alamos when I went there to meet a
DARPA scientist who was working on an artificial brain for DARPA.
I mean this stuff is way brain trying to create a system,
you know, a free thinking system and what his name was Garrett Kenyon.
What he told me, it was just utterly fascinating because again,
that human thing I'm always after. It's like, what are you doing? I mean,
leave the science. You've had lots of guys on here.
I'll talk to you about the high technology elements,
but I'm interested in who's doing that, who's creating that science and why.
And he said to me, this is like,
like where artificial intelligence is right now with scientists who are really
looking into this. It's like Magellan, you know,
like who will discover the new world? But on the,
on the idea of frightening artificial intelligence,
he told me an interesting story about his daughter and he said, um,
people seem to think like, you know,
facial recognition software is like telling us that we're one step away from AI,
true AI. And he said if, if he's, he was,
he showed me on his iPhone,
this was a couple of years ago and how much trouble the iPhone had recognizing
him. Like if he put a hat on or if he made a funny face and he said,
my daughter can recognize me from across a baseball field.
You know, if I have a hat on, just by the way I walk. Right? And he said,
if she, if she couldn't, there would be something really wrong with her.
In other words,
her human recognition abilities are truly intelligent and that is a system of
systems, a biological system of systems that no scientist has, you know,
the algorithm for which no one has ever been able to figure out yet.
And he believes that we're far away from that.
But the defense department on the other hand is moving us in that direction and
absolutely wants autonomous weapons to be fighting Wars. Look,
there was a program that said, um, I quote this in the book, it says the, um,
the battle place is no place for humans.
So drones are the way of the future, right?
But they're used to kill people, which,
which also means that the enemy is creating drone systems.
And pretty soon that's going to be a big, a big issue. The big fear,
the big fear is that they're going to be the first ones to implement it. I mean,
what scares you about
everything? DARPA thinks AI could help troops,
telepathically control much machines. Of course they do.
And then they probably can.
I mean they've already got cursors that people can move around that are
paraplegic, they can move them around with their mind in their eyes. Yeah,
I think there's going to be a quite a few of those things.
What does this [inaudible], and this is called the synapse. This is a,
I'll look read this thing.
That's DOE DARPA funded program develop electronic neuro morphic machine
technology that scales to biological levels more simply stated,
it is an attempt to build a new kind of computer with similar form and function
to the mammalian brain.
Such artificial brains would be used to build robots whose intelligence matches
that of mice and cats. Jesus Christ, robot cats,
robot cats coming to get us.
Well, they created something called the robo rat. That was the first,
um, bio hybrid, right? So a bio hybrid is when you mix a animal and a machine.
And DARPA was doing that, um, right before nine 11.
And people freaked out. They were like,
you cannot put brain chips and rats and make them move through a maze by,
uh, you know, remote control, which was what they were doing.
And I interviewed the guys who were all working on this program before nine 11.
And so the, the morality of the,
of the citizenry was like, no.
Then nine 11 happened and suddenly all this money got pumped into DARPA to do
anything they wanted.
The morality issue went out the window and they started creating all kinds of
bio hybrids as I write in the Pentagon's brain. So they put, um, they,
they now have pigeons that are mixed, you know,
animal and machine. They created something called, there's a moth.
So there's a Manduka sex to moth. That's what it's called, is a large moth.
And sine DARPA, scientists put brain chips into the larva. Okay.
So that when it cocooned and became a flying moth,
it had the,
the chip built into its system,
making it easier to integrate and they could fly the moth around the lap.
And that was a huge step.
And this is now four years ago that I was interviewing these scientists.
Did you see any of this stuff? I didn't see them off, but I, I told you,
I saw that the limb regeneration lap was a trip. And this is all sprint.
Well,
they were just cutting limbs off of salamanders and watching the limbs grow
back. Right. And examining that and saying, well, if a salamander can do this,
so can we one day. And I said to them, but wait, that's impossible. You know?
And they said, well it's not actually because humans have, they broke.
I love scientists who break it down into terms I can understand.
It's like what Elon did, you know? Right. Cause and they said to me,
you were once a single cell in your mother's womb and then you were two and then
you were, you know, right. So you can regenerate.
And that's their premise.
I mean these are the tops on the world's top scientist in regeneration.
What is this Jamie?
The moth being stimulated by electro occurrence and its abdomen.
So the stimulation of the electro occurrence,
they can cause it to go left or right. Is that it? Yeah,
I was looking up these bio hybrid MOS.
What was the thing that you threw your hands in your head?
You were freaking out. Macaulay Culkin in home alone.
This guy's reading something. He went, Oh yeah. I typed in,
I started typing in bio hybrid stuff,
and this is the first thing that popped up. Was this a shrimp article? Yeah.
It says throw it. They're going to test them through Olympic themed events.
Oh my God. Look at this.
DARPA MTO seeks innovative proposals for the development of micro to Millie
insect scale robotic technologies. Shrimp were developed. We'll develop.
Okay, so shrimp is the
an acronym. Probably they, they love an acronym.
We'll develop and demonstrate through a series of Olympic themed events,
multifunctional M M to C M scale robotic platforms,
so I guess that's millimeter to centimeter scale robotic platforms with a focus
on untethered mobility, maneuverability, and dexterity to achieve this goal.
Shrimp will also provide foundational research in the area of micro actual
actuator materials and endure energy efficient power systems for extremely swap
capital. Letter S, copy level w, lowercase a,
capital P constrained microbiotic systems. They expect as such,
advances will be enabling for applications including search and rescue. Yeah,
right. Search and rescue. Disaster relief. Yay.
We're going to help people hazardous environment inspection or killing
motherfuckers with a, with an evil nuclear B,
that's all you need is B that goes in your mouth and blows up.
Fuck, that's crazy.
I mean they do all kinds of planning for the future,
but the search and rescue thing is a, it's a great sort of, you know,
way in which to present DARPA as doing all this great stuff.
I interviewed DARPA scientists who said, look Andy, we've got,
we're able to send robots into Fukushima to twist the right then.
And yes, that is great, but that's far from the only thing that's been right.
Yeah, well, yeah, but here's a trip you want to hear. I mean it gets,
there are rabbit holes there because I sourced all these documents and also
interviewed generals at the Pentagon who were like, we don't like a AI.
We want like, we want this, we want our guys on the ground. You know, we,
they believe in the, the warrior, that concept.
And so the generals were very opposed with the,
DARPA took a vote and it was like, no AI. We want humans in the mix.
And so what a DARPA start doing, and they owe the generals. They said,
why don't you, why can't we go more autonomous? And the answer was,
we don't trust the machines. Okay?
So right around that same time, what a DARPA start doing,
it started looking into and hiring scientists who were working with how trust
works in the brain, specifically with what is called the moral molecule.
And it's this molecule in the brain that mothers emit when they're
breastfeeding. Okay? Oxytocin. Yes. So think about that.
And I mean, that's like the ultimate going way back biology.
Like you have to have a mother, a trusting mother to breastfeed in,
you know, pre history or otherwise you'd be eaten by, you'd be like,
this is a bad idea. I'm stopping to do this, I'm going to die. Right?
So they examined that molecule,
the brain's moral molecule,
and they began a program to work with that,
to be able to give that to soldiers so that they're,
that they trusted AI machines.
And that's where I think you're getting into a really spooky,
dark multi levels of manipulation about what humans want versus what the
Pentagon wants.
Wow.
The worry about trusting the machines scares the shit out of me because that's
what everyone's worried about when it comes to AI.
Like that's what Elon Musk keeps warning people about,
that these things are going to have superhuman capabilities and they're going to
be sentient. And it's a matter of when.
Absolutely. So I, I, as the journalist said to myself, well wait a minute.
If the generals at the Pentagon, and I'm, you know, that's a,
that's a euphemism, but the meaning that the actual opera, you know,
the guys that are in charge here don't want that. Who does want this?
And where my research took me to was the group that wants,
that is what's called the defense science board.
And those are the individuals who are counseling the Pentagon in the manner in
which they should proceed.
And now those individuals are all sitting on the boards of the defense
contractors.
So you can really see how money drives the rubric.
The generals don't want it. The humans don't want it. But guess who does?
The people who stand to make the money creating the autonomous systems.
And that's exactly what Eisenhower warned us of in his farewell speech.
You know, the military industrial complex. And the other part of that speech,
which people don't, don't know as well, is that what he said, his antidote,
Eisenhower said this,
the antidote to the military industrial complex is an alert and knowledgeable
citizenry. It's why I write my books,
because an alert and knowledgeable citizenry has the ability to kind of push
back and go, but we don't want that. Well, I think what we're worried
about is Pandora's box, right with when it comes to AI. And we're worried that,
first of all, if we're not the ones to open it, what if they open it? All right?
What if the Chinese open it now and obviously their technology is super,
super advanced. I mean their electronic technology particular,
their cell phones are cutting edge. I mean,
Apple and all these other companies are struggling to try to keep up with Walway
in these one FC or a one, um, X. What is the fucking one?
S T what does that one, what does that big company
that uh, they just released some,
they've just hired Robert Downey jr to give him millions of dollars to on one
plus one plus seven. They have this,
a new phone that doesn't have a front facing camera. You press a button,
it slides out of the top. They figured out a way to make it the entire phone,
all screen. And they're incredibly advanced in terms of their electronics. We,
we deeply are concerned that they're going to be the ones that implement
military autonomous,
sentient robotics before we do.
Because then you can essentially,
you can launch them with no physical human cost on your side.
And I mean they, they,
they're literally weapons of mass destruction if you have robots that can go
over there and just kill people.
And, and what they need for that is the world's fastest supercomputer. Right.
And what's interesting is that we just, we,
America just overtook the Chinese in having, again,
having the world's fastest super computer,
but they had it for a couple of years and think about this. Okay.
Cause you were saying hard to believe the Nazis were only, you know,
not even like.